This is one of the top five chapters in one
piece. And if you haven't read it yet, FLY
YOU FOOL. AND ONLY COME BACK ONCE YOU HAVE.
But if you have, welcome to another week of
me breaking my vow to not talk about a new
chapter for the second time in a row.
I have so many theories to share, told you
sos to say and things to analyize here.
Here's a quick recap. You know, In case you
forgot what just happened.
Luffy has fully awakened his devil fruit,
which he has now declared his Gear 5. The
Gorosei reveal that the real name of the GOmu
GOmu no mi is actually the Mythical Human
Human Zoan fruit model Nika, very likely the
most powerful devil fruit there is.
While it seems like Luffy has not exactly
been possessed by Joy Boy, he clearly isn't
quite himself either. His battle with Kaido
is absolutely boro-breathtaking and Kaido
apologising to Luffy is exactly in line with
my character analysis of him I published two
days ago.
There is also the fact that Luffy's hair turned
into fire, like in this sketch that Oda made
of LUffy as street fighter ken. Also his eyebrows
start curling, very similar to Sanji huh.
And his eyes take on the same ring-like shape
that is shared by a very crazy group of characters:
Imu, Mihawk and Zunesha.
Also, what a power move by Oda calling it
the Nika Nika fruit. Remember how people thought
it had to be the gomu fruit because of the
word plays with the straw hats devil fruits.
All numbers from one to ten.
Choppers Hito Hito is 1 and ten, brook's yomi
yomi no mi is 4 and 3, Robin's Hana Hana was
8 and 7 and Luffy was gomu, so 5 and 6. That
left 2 and 9, which lead people to belive
that it might be Kuma's Ni kyuu ni kyy fruit.
Well turns out it's not Nikyuu but Nika, another
reading for 9. Luffy was 2 and 9 after all.
That leaves 5 and 6 open again and the only
fruit we know right now that fits that is
Enel's Goro Goro no mi. Just throwing it out
there.
Now, once again it was as impossible to escape
spoilers for all this for even a minute, as
it is to take a poop without your phone. Imagine.
So of course, as soon as there was so much
as a whisper about what would happen, the
comment sections under all my videos were
flooded. My Twitter was flooded. People nailed
print outs of the spoilers to my door. Well,
maybe not that last one, but that's what it
felt like.
And so apparently, my way of teaching people
a lesson, is by giving in to their demands
and talking about this. Because if this doesn't
have your blood boiling, I don't know what
will. I will dissect for you what exactly
this mythical creature Nika is, and what its
true powers are.
Before dedicating this entire video to Luffy
and Kaido, I want to at least acknowledge
the scene between Hiyori and Orochi with a
sentence or two, even though, let's be real,
no one cares in the context of this chapter.
Still, I found it both very surprising and
satisfying to see Orochi dying at the hands
of Kanjuro, especially because it was his
own fault. Orochi literally told him to cast
everyone in the castle into the abyss of hell
and Free their souls, Kanjuro, freeUSin
a blaze of glory. US. Free US in a blaze of
glory.
To which Kanjuro said, As you wish, please
enjoy my final show,The suicide pact of
the Kurozumi clan. Galaxy brain move from
Orochi right there. Funny stuff, but not as
funny as what's up next.
So, here's my first I told you so. God that
sounds so cocky. But I have to take the few
wins I can get. Luffy is a mythical Zoan fruit.
As fun as the resin idea was, as one hilarious
comment on my video pointed out, it made very
little sense for the government to rename
the resin fruit into the rubber fruit.
As if anyone would go 'oh no, it was the resin
fruit all along. Now I really wish I had gotten
my hand on that'. All mythical fruits we have
gotten so far, with the sole exceptions of
Sengoku and Catarina Devone, who might very
well still appear this arc, have been in Wano.
And both the Buddha and the Kitsune are heavily
connected to Japanese culture.
As I've mentioned a bunch of videos, Wano
is based on the story of Momotaro. Momotaro,
with the help of a pheasant, a dog and a monkey,
goes to Onigashima to defeat the Oni. So we
have Kaido, a mythical Zoan, Momo a mythical
Zoan, the mythical dog Yamato, the mythical
bird, Marco and so there really was just one
logical candidate left for the mythical monkey
fruit. Usopp.
I'm just messing with you.
And so It turns out that Luffy's rubber abilities
are just a natural property of the sun god
Nika. Similarly to how Marco has access to
fire or how Yamato can create ice. It's the
paramecia properties of a mythical zoan. Changing
the name to the gomu gomu no mi is very smart,
because it basically reduces the Nika fruit
to its most unimpressive ability. Rubber.
It's kind of like saying Marco's fruit is
a weaker version of Ace's mera mera no mi
or like Sengoku having the gold fruit.
So now Luffy has mythical Zoan powers, advanced
forms of all 3 types of Haki and an awakened
devil fruit. Oh yeah, Plus the voice of all
things. So, I think it's pretty fair to say
that this is pretty close to endgame Luffy
right now, alright!
I do stand by my idea however, that Luffy
will have to learn to control and use his
awakening after Wano. I doubt it will be something
he can just do every single time from now
on, whenever he wants to.
Luffy turning out to be a Zoan type is also
incredibly funny in retrospect. Remember this
panel where momo asks Luffy how he can turn
back into his human form on Punk Hazard? Luffy
literally says, don't ask me, I'm not a Zoan
fruit.
Well turns out Luffy you are and you basically
have spent your entire life in your hybrid
form since you were 8 years old. Which is
just such a Luffy thing to do.
In a way this scene was pretty big foreshadowing
as well, because Momo and Luffy are the only
two people in the story that truly struggle
with their devil fruit powers after they get
them. Other characters like Kalifa can use
their fruit pretty decently right away, because
they fully understand what their power is.
Luffy however thinks that his fruit is the
rubber fruit, making it incredibly hard to
work with at the beginning.
It also explains Luffy's crazy stamina and
endurance as well as his fast recovery time.
That's exactly the benefits all Zoans, and
mythical Zoans in particular are associated
with.
On top of that, we have another straw hat
with a human fruit type devil fruit, chopper,
who makes all of this so much more interesting.
Luffy's gear system is very very similar to
Chopper's different forms.
While everyone was looking at Katakuri and
Dofi when it comes to LUffy's awakening, Chopper
was there all along. His point system and
LUffy's gear system. And monster point might
truly be foreshadowing for giant Luffy, which,
looking at his giant arm in this chapter,
is very possible.
Then he could also wear the giant straw hat
hidden away in Marijois. Chopper turning into
a chibi earlier I the raid also reminded me
a lot of Tiny Luffy before he can control
Gear 3. Post time skip they both came back
being able to switch between their forms with
little to no setback.
The only real question then is: Will Luffy
eat a rumble ball? And what will happen?
But let's talk a little about the fruit itself.
Clearly Shanks knew exactly what it was when
he stole it. Shanks was clearly tasked by
Roger to find the right person to become joy
boy. He had no choice, but to bet everything
on Luffy, the only person who could now become
joy boy.
Rayleigh knew as well of course, which is
why he was so surprised to see how luffy used
his fruit's powers, despite only being aware
of a fraction of its true capabilities. It
also makes me wonder, whether shanks didn't
talk to the gorosei about luffy, when he visited.
Telling them about LUffy having the fruit,
which is how they found out in the first place.
I still don't think its likely that Shanks
is the villain of the story, but it definitely
makes you question his motives. Maybe shanks
knew that luffy would have to die in order
to awaken it, and pushed to government to
make a hasty move, as they ended up doing.
Not fully understanding how the fruit worked.
Similarly it's possible that Blackbeard did
confuse the Yami Yami no mi with the Nika
Nika no mi. But honestly, I think that these
two fruits look very similar for a reason.
They probably are a pair. The sun and Darkness.
[]
this would make sense thematically also, because
luffy's rubber powers also are a great counter
to the gura gura no mi's earthquake powers.
The only question is, if blackbeard acquires
a third fruit, what would Luffy's third ability
be? Just food for thought.
Now as we know got confirmed, the Gomu Gomu,
or rather the Nika Nika no mi, wow that will
take a while to get used to huh. The Nika
Nika no mi was a key ingredient in awakening
joy boy. Now you might have seen my video
on the true nature of devil fruits, in which
I lay out proof for these fruits being alive
and carrying on the will of their previous
owner.
If you haven't I heavily recommend you check
that out in full later. And we literally get
the confirmation for that from the Gorosei
themselves. Zoan fruits specifically have
a will of their own.
Which makes sense, all the objects that have
eaten fruits, like the sword Funkfreed or
the canon that became a dog on alabasta, have
all had zoan fruits and took on their personalities.
Caesars smile fruits were all based on animals.
They're called smiles, as if in reference
to Joy Boys smile. So maybe the smiles were
part of Kaido's plan to awaken Joy Boy somehow.
And it's also ironic how he will now be defeated
by the only true smile fruit. Who knows, Maybe
this is also the answer to vegapunk deeming
momos dragon fruit a failure. Maybe he was
able to replicate the fruits abilities, but
could not inherit the will of the original
into the copy.
Luffy's fruit was trying to escape the hands
of the government. Now I think it is pretty
much confirmed at this point, that the Nika
fruit used to belong to Joy Boy. And so as
I have speculated for a while now, it seems
like eating the Nika Nika fruit inherited
part of Joy Boys will onto Luffy.
I don'T think however, that Luffy became who
he is because of eating that fruit. I think
that Shanks wanted to give this fruit to ace,
the son of his former captain Roger, who wanted
kids in order to create Joy Boy. And while
looking for ace in Fusha Village, the will
of Joy boy in the fruit chose Luffy as its
worthy owner. Think of it in terms of Thors
hammer.
Luffy always was the embodiment of what it
meant to be Joy Boy. He has been freeing people
from their burden and bringing the joy and
hope his entire life. He did that with every
one of his crew members.
Freeing Zoro from his capture, Nami from her
burden, Robin form her Darkness and so on
and so forth. He freed Katakuri from his burden
to be the perfect older brother, Ace from
his chains. And of course entire countries
from their tyrannical rulers. It's Luffy's
character arc. Liberation. Joy Boys drums
of liberation.
And now, here in Wano, where Luffy is fighting
and dying for the liberation of the people
of Wano, in the night of the fire festival,
where they send their prayers to the spirits
of their ancestors, Joy Boy's will has finally
acknowledged Luffy's spirit and awakened the
true power of the sun gods powers for the
first time in 800 years.
Luffy's heartbeat is literally the drums of
liberation. The sound that brings hope to
the oppressed. Another I told you so moment,
I mentioned in the last chapter how Oda-sensei
put a lot of focus on that heart sound effect
in Luffy's closeup.
I also absolutely love Kaido's reaction to
Luffy being alive in this chapter. I love
him more and more as a villain the more we
see him. Apologizing to Luffy for how he won
this fight is exactly in line with what I
said in his character analysis this week.
Kaido wants to be the good guy, but plays
the villain because he thinks he is the only
one who can change the world. He strayed from
his path trying to force joy boy's awakening,
disqualifying himself in the process by using
the people of wano. Plus he didn't have the
Nika fruit of course. Luffy will liberate
Kaido from his heavy burden as well.
We will see kaido genuinely laughing again
and I think he will end up being on Luffy's
side at the end of this fight. Now, while
possible in theory, I doubt Kaido will actually
be by Luffy's side at the final battle, but
much rather sacrifice his life for the straw
hats when the marines or Blackbeard will inevitably
arrive at some point.
That way finally getting the honourable death
he always wanted, having successfully brought
about Joy Boys return. And fingers crossed
really hard, it will be Yamato who will join
the straw hats and represent him by Luffy's
side.
With all that out of the way now, I want to
dig deep into Luffy's power and what the Nika
Nika fruit is actually based on. Because the
internet has researched this name to death
and it's not an obvious mythical creature
like a phoenix or a dragon.
It seems like Nika is a mixture of a couple
of different ideas. One element is that of
the buddhist wisdom king deity. Hyogoro calls
luffy wisdom king myo for instance. It's also
referenced by Enel, who has a wisdom king
slash buddha like form, who also calls himself
a god.
And Skypea of course was the arc that has
the famous panel, where Luffy looks like Nika
which is again referenced in this chapter.
Since wisdom kings have fiery hair too, that
might explain that part of his ability as
well.
Another part of Nika, might be inspired by
the Olmecs, one of the oldest known civilisations
in the americas. The word olmec literally
means Rubber People in English, as they actually
were able to produce rubber and cultivate
rubber trees. It also might be a nod to the
aztec god of rubber, who is called *deep breath
in* Tlauixcalpantecuhtli. Nailed it.
This god's name translated means the lord
of the house of the dawn, which fits pretty
nicely to the one who brings the dawn, dont
you think? This god was also associated with
the sun gods, representing the Eastern cardinal
direction. Not only would that tie in nicely
with Dragon's aztec tattoo and Luffy being
from Brazil, but the dawn is also the sun
rising in the east. Luffy coming form the
east blue.
So we might know what Nika is inspired by,
but what are Luffy's actual powers? Because
there seem to be two things in addition to
his fire powers, that seem new. One Luffy's
Toon World like powers, that seem to turn
everything around him into a cartoon. And
two his fire powers. To me at least, these
two don't seem to be the same thing.
Now there is actually a fantastic theory I
have for you guys, that Luffy's fire powers
are actually not related to his devil fruit,
but due to Luffy being half Lunarian, the
old gods. Like kings flames and Sanji's eyebrows.
If you want to hear that theory next week,
make sure to subscribe to the channel.
Another option for his fire powers that was
sent to me by Renato, is that since Nika is
the sun god, Luffy might just have the powers
of the sun itself, quite literally. Especially
since the sun is a reoccurring symbol in the
story.
The theory in itself is very science heavy,
which is awesome, but what you need to know
here, is that a star like the sun is basically
a giant fusion reactor. We have seen luffy
using gas and heat to modify his body, which
seems to work in a similar matter to plasma,
the fourth state of matter, that is heated
gas.
Luffy tells us that he cant let the gas escape
his body or it's over. So luffy literally
seeming to melt, might be him heating up and
creating plasma inside his rubber body, using
the power of the sun itself to unleash incredible
forces. As binks sake said, the morning sun
will rise.
And while I like this idea a lot, it doesn't
explain the cartoony part of his powers. What's
the deal with that? Well, basically since
day 1 Luffy's fighting style has always been
cartoonish but he had limitations (like when
he tried the spinny spinny attack on Arlong
and got stuck and almost died in the process).
Similar to Yu-Gi-Oh, toon powers are incredible
because they can go against the laws of time,
space, gravity, and so on. It truly seems
to allow Luffy to Fight in any way he pleases.
Like expanding his limbs, changing the world
around him and ignoring how physics work.
As the Gorosei explain: Making people laugh
wherever it goes, It's the most ridiculous
power in the world. Maybe quite literally
as Luffy can turn things into a funny cartoon.
Which would be the most Oda-like thing to
do.
But knowing this by itself isn't enough yet,
we will need to see Luffy's fight with Kaido
play out in full to really understand Luffy's
true powers.
And that's why you really shouldn't skip this
video here, where I explain in detail how
Kaido tried to awaken this power himself and
what it means for the end of this fight.